[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir voilà un an
etnemi que valerrieardesttin n'avait
tenu de conférence de presse ce ritth
traditionnel de la réunion du chef de
l'État et des journalistes avait pris un
rythme soutenu au début de son mandat 5
fois en 2 ans et demi mais depuis la
multiplication des élections M mpale
puis législative avait empêché que cela
se reproduise et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on attendait beaucoup de cette
conférence de cet après-midi tout avait
été fait pour la solaniser 400
journalistes des tentures or et pastel
une nouvelle disposition de la salle
comme autant du président Pompidou et du
génal de Gaulle la pendule fétiche du
grand-père du président le petit bouquet
de fleurs et deœillet blanc et rouge
bref tout était prêt cet après-midi à
16h pour une réunion qui a finalement
duré un peu plus que prévu 2h en tout et
d'emblé valériegardestin a rappelé le
choix des Français il y a 3 mois en
montrant ce qu'avait changé ces
élections dans la vie politique
française et où en était le pays dans
une période qui est une période où il
n'y a pas d'échéance électorale
immédiate où la l'opposition est amenée
à reconsidérer en profondeur sa tactique
et son ses programmes où la majorité va
poursuivre une action que je vais avoir
l'occasion de décrire en réponse à vos
questions et où en même temps il m'a
paru nécessaire de poursuivre mon effort
en direction d'une ouverture
politique cette ouverture politique il
faut toujours en voir l'objet
exact cette ouverture c'est de créer en
France les conditions d'une cohabitation
raisonnable entre les formations
démocratiques et ça n'est pas de
modifier l'équilibre politique par des
initiatives improvisées de débauchage ou
de Man uvre à court terme j'ai pris à
cet égard un certain nombre
d'initiatives dans le sens de
l'ouverture elles ont commencé à
modifier le paysage politique de la
France je dis bien commencer puisqu'il
s'agit de modifier les habitudes et que
rien n'est plus long que le changement
des habitudes c'est là qu'en effet un
peu plus tard le président devait
davantage expliciter ce qu'alait être
ses initiatives dans le sens de
l'ouverture et devant les journalistes
plus tard devant le Parlement il a
ouvert trois dossiers trois dossiers
concrets no Copa euh oui ces trois
dossiers le président de la République
demande au Premier ministre de les
ouvrir lui-même en présence avec les
représentants de la majorité mais aussi
avec les représentants de l'opposition
ce sont trois dossiers qui concernent la
vie démocratique française trois
dossiers dont on parle déjà depuis
longtemps sur lesquels il y a pas encore
une décision premier dossier le cumul
des mandats le président de la
République estime qu'il faut diminuer ce
cumul et pour mieux répartir les
responsabilité il souhaite que chacun ne
puisse pas avoir plus de deux mandats
électifs deux mandats nationaux dit
d'ailleurs oui et deuxième dossier le
financement des partis politiques le
président de la République critique le
financement clandestin il souhaite un
financement régulier et il souhaite
l'instauration d'un système qui soit
misise en place très vite dès le 1er
janvier 1980 3è dossier le mode de
scrutin des élections locales autrement
dit des élections municipales le
président de la République a critiqué le
système actuel dans les villes de plus
de 30000 habitants système de majorité
de liste bloquée et il souhaite un
scrutin de type proportionnel et puis il
a fait un pas de plus en direction de
l'opposition à propos du droit de
réponse à la télévision souvent demandé
par les formations politiques il a
d'abord rappelé qu'en ce moment ces
différentses formation ont un accès très
libre à la télévision qu'à cet égard la
campagne électorale n'avait été entachée
d'aucune bavure et qu'il laissait toute
l'attitude à la responsabilité des
présidents de chînne et de leur conseil
d'administration et c'est là qu'il a
expliqué ce que seraiit les modalités du
droit de réponse à venir lorsque le
Premier ministre ou un membre du
gouvernement s'exprime eximerait par
utilisation de la faculté que les textes
donnent en effet au gouvernement de
s'adresser au pays sur les ondes des
grands
médias et lorsque ce sujet ne ferait pas
l'objet en même temps d'un débat devant
le Parlement cette précaution étant pour
éviter que le Parlement nit le sentiment
que on veut le dessaisir d'un débat et
le traiter directement vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique donc lorsque le
gouvernement utiliserait cette faculté
l'opposition
disposerait sur la même chaîne s'il
s'agit de la télévision ou sur le même
instrument s'il s'agit de la
radio dans un délai de 48 he et à la
même heure
d'écoute d'un temps de réponse égal à
celui de la communication qui aurait été
faite ce temps de réponse serait réparti
par le conseil d'administration du moyen
d'expression en question
entre les dirigeants de l'opposition
suivant des règles à établir et donc
pour une durée totale identique à celle
de la communication du gouvernement et
cette réponse serait ensuite suivie d'un
débat d'un débat paritaire entre
représentant de l'opposition et
représentant de la majorité ou du
gouvernement sur le même sujet c'est
donc ainsi que serait organisé ce droit
de réponse ça suppose d'ailleurs
certaines modifications des cahiers des
charges des sociétés de programme et le
ministre de la Communication va étudier
ce point je voudrais pas cependant faire
naître à cet égard des illusions parce
que en fait à l'heure actuelle
l'expression est très large sur nos
moyen et il faut savoir que depuis les
élections le Premier ministre ne s'est
pas adressé à l'opinion publique par la
voix de précisément cette communication
directe il y a eu des débats avec des
journalistes comme il continuera bien
avoir mais ces débats naturellement ne
peuvent pas eux ouvrir droit à une
réponse oui à propos de l'accès des
formations politiques à la télévision
j'indique d'ailleurs que François
mitteran sera notre invité mardi soir
dans le cadre de ce journal de 20h puis
al Noël copain le le président a
également évoqué mais alors plus
rapidement les problèmes institutionnels
et puis ceux de la majorité oui les
institutions le président de la
République n'envisage pas à l'heure
actuelle de réformes constitutionnel le
seul problème dit-il sur lequel il
pourrait prendre une initiative c'est le
problème déjà ancien et très complexe du
régime des suppléants la majorité les
choses vont comme elles doivent aller
estime le président de la République le
pluralisme reprenant une expression
qu'il a employé l' dernière le
pluralisme fonctionne effectivement
d'une manière organisée enfin d'un
revers de main et avec vous le verrez
une pointe d'humour il a répondu à
l'interrogation de l'un de mes confrères
sur son éventuelle candidature en 81
c'est-à-dire au terme de son mandat un
des résultats très importants des
élections de mars 1978 c'était d'avoir
mis fin à presque 5 ans de campagne
électorale ininterrompu alors ne comptez
pas sur moi pour commencer 3 ans à
l'avance la préparation d'une éventuelle
campagne et puis j'irai plus loin
pourquoi êtesvous si pressé je constate
avec vous tous que un des grands
problèmes un des grands drames de notre
temps c'est cette fuite incessante et
précipitée du temps pourquoi ne
donnez-vous pas au temps le droit de
respirer ainsi s achevé la partie
politique de la conférence de presse
présidentielle deè tête de chapitre le
dossier économique et social avec
d'emblé une affirmation pour dissiper
tout mal entendu il n'y a qu'une
politique il n'y a pas le giscardisme
d'un côté le barisme de l'autre cette
politique c'est celle que conduit le
gouvernement de Monsieur bar que je lui
ai demandé de conduire et que
naturellement j'approuve valérieardestin
voulait ainsi répondre aux critiques de
ceux qui trouvaient que la politique de
Raymond bar était un peu trop brutale
notamment en matière de chômage puisque
vous le savez le gouvernement a décidé
d'assaainir l'économie avec tous les
risques que cela peut porter sur l'
emploi dans les secteurs en difficulté
il n'y a pas de secteur condamnés il y a
des entreprises à réorganiser ce qui
n'est pas la même chose par exemple on
fait croire qu'il y a des secteurs dans
lesquels il est pas c'est plus la peine
d'essayer de produire en France tel que
le textile je vous rappelle que
l'industrie textile française est
exportatrice nette j'ai regardé exprès
les chiffres pour l'année dernière
l'année dernière la France a exporté
1illard 300 millions de francs de
textile fini textile fin de plus qu'elle
enen a importé cela prouve donc qu'il y
a dans l'industrie textile des créneaux
des spécialités dans laquelle la France
peut reconstituer une supériorité de
compétition ou de technologie deuxème
exemple
l'industrie pour la dernière année où on
connaisse les chiffres qui est
1975 l'industrie de l'Allemagne fédérale
représente 170 % de l'industrie
française en production 170 %. et la
population employée dans dans
l'industrie de l'Allemagne fédérale
représente 130 % 140 % de la population
employée dans l'industrie française donc
si nous développions notre industrie au
niveau de l'Allemagne fédérale tous nos
problèmes d'emploi disparaissent donc ça
la prouve bien premièrement qu'il y a
pas de secteur condamné et deuxièmement
qu'il y a une marge d'action et de
développement pour la France permettant
de régler ces problèmes d'emploi bon à
travers tous ces propos de valestin
est-ce qu'on peut définir PHPP c'est une
philosophie politique ou une correction
de cap ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
comme pendant la campagne électorale à
montsoléi le président met de nouveau
l'acent sur l'industrie son idée
centrale et bien la compétition
internationale est devenue plus rude
surtout avec les pays en voie de
développement mais la France peut et
doit sortir de la crise bref nous avons
perdu des batailles c'està-dire des
marchés économiques mais nous n'avons
pas perdu cette guerre économique mais
cependant si la France veut retrouver le
peloton de tête des pays industriels qui
sont justement sortis de la crise il
faut qu' utilise les mêmes moyens que
ces fameux pays qui ont réussi il faut
que la formation professionnelle soit
mieux adaptée à nos besoins économiques
il faut orienter l'épargne là où l'on
peut créer des emplois il faut que les
entreprises retrouvent davantage de
responsabilités sous-entendu de liberté
enfin il faut que cet effort économique
s'accompagne d'un effort social et puis
surtout le président a annoncé la mise à
l'étude avec application à titre
exceptionnel l'année prochaine d'une
mesure destinée à favoriser
l'actionnariat ouvrier plus précisément
et comme il ne faut pas schématiser dans
ce domaine il s'agit d'aider les
travailleurs et les employés des
entreprises à accéder à la propriété du
capital de leurs entreprises alors je
vous laisse écouter le président à ce
sujet le gouvernement a préparé un
certain nombre de mesures pour conduire
les Français à devenir plus largement
propriétaire de l'industrie de la France
et un certain nombre de mesures
d'incitation à l'épargne d'avantages
fiscaux comme vous le savez qui serait
introduit en ce qui concerne concerne
l'impôt sur le revenu la création de
techniques nouvelles fond commun de
placement de d'action à dividendes
prioritaires vont conduire les Français
à acquérir une part croissante de la
propriété de leur industrie et c'est une
très bonne chose mais naturellement une
démarche de ce genre sera inévitablement
lente puisque elle suppose une
acquisition annuelle et progressive
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il faudrait
lancer le mouvement par une décision
immédiate portant sur la diffusion de la
propriété du capital
industriel et cette décision pourrait
être la
suivante une mesure exceptionnelle
serait
prise en vue de l'accession à la
propriété du capital d'entreprise
industrielle et commerciale par les
travailleurs et les employés de
celles-ci cette mesure pourrait
intervenir en 19
79 sous la forme suivante une
augmentation de capital exonéré
d'impôts
et donnant lieu à distribution gratuite
d'action au personnel salariés et
employés des
entreprises selon des modalités déduites
des procédures de
l'intéressement et pouvant atteindre 5 %
du montant du
capital
cette action doit être conduite dans des
conditions
équitables c'est-à-dire en faisant en
sorte que la l'attribution des actions
se passe à l'intérieur d'une clé
relativement modéré je dirais par
exemple de 1 à 3 entre celui qui reçoit
le moins et celui qui reçoit le plus
puisque c'est l'ensemble des salariés
qui serait bénéficiire de ces
attributions et sans créer de préjudice
à l'économie et à épargne ce qui veut
dire que des dispositions seraient
prises
parallèlement pour maintenir intact la
capacité bénéficiaire des titres
actuellement détenus par les
actionnaires
ou en quelque sorte il faut résumer
Philippe il s'agit surtout d'une d'une
extension de la formule de la
participation oui alors quelles sont les
modalités et bien ce qu'on peut dire on
peut faire quatre remarques l'an
prochain une partie du capital des
grandes société celles qui sont côté en
bourse sera distribué gratuitement à
leurs employés le montant maximum de ces
ution sera 5 % de ce capital
deuxièmement c'est une mesure
exceptionnelle c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne
sera pas renouvelée après 1979 ensuite
le président espère que les Français
prendront le goût à l'actionnariat il
espère il souhaite que les Français
prennent le goût d'un certain
capitalisme populaire il souhaite pour
cela que les mesures en faveur de
l'épargne soient efficaces troisièmement
en contre-partie de cette distribution
gratuite certaines mesures probablement
d'ordre fiscal seront prises pour
dédommager les anciens actionnaires les
actionnaires capitalistes traditionnels
à qui on on demande de partager
gratuitement leurs gâteaux ces mesures
n'ont pas encore été arrêtées alors
effectivement comme vous le disiez le
général de Gaul avait souhaité
intéresser les Français au bénéfice de
leur entreprise giscardestin lui Valérie
giscardestin souhaite les intéresser et
bien directement au capital c'est une
formule qui est déjà utilisé en
Allemagne alors troisième volet encore
qu'il soit difficile de dissocier les
deux mais nous le faisons pour la
commodité de l'analyse le volet social
avec d'abord une réponse à l'un de nos
confrères François Henr Virieux sur le
chômage écoutez la question et la répon
tique pratiqué actuellement en France si
elle réussit est de nature à assurer un
emploi à chaque français dans les années
qui nous sépare de la fin du
siècle ma réponse est très simple c'est
oui n'est- pas dans les Sondag les
enquêtes que l'on fait à l'heure
actuelle sont utiles d'ailleurs on pose
des questions auxquelles je consid moême
qu' est très difficile de répondre on
demande à quelqu'un approuvez-vous les
hausses de tarifs des entreprises
nationales il peut répondre que non si
vous avez à payer une facture de gaz
d'électricité acheter du charbon qu'on
vous demande est-ce que vous êtes
partisan de la os vous répondez NON je
vois pas comment on peut répondre
d'ailleurs autrement donc la question
n'est pas de savoir si une
politique doit être perçu comme étant
approuvé dans ces détails la question de
savoir si une politique est nécessaire
et si elle est utile vous savez qu'avec
les hausses de tarifs qui ont qui ont eu
lieu qui sont importantes qui sont
lourdes et donc je suis tout à fait
conscient que dans un foyer lorsqu'on
voit arrivver à la fin de mois les notes
tout ceci c'est très lourd et qu'on se
dit pourquoi nous demande-t-on des des
efforts des contributions de cette
nature il faut savoir que malgré cela
les versements que le budget c'est les
Français au total devront faire aux
entreprises nationales l'année prochaine
malgré les augmentation de tarifs
n'est-ce pas seront encore de l'ordre de
30 milliards de francs et donc il était
nécessaire il est nécessaire d'aboutir à
une situation de meilleur équilibre et
je suis persuadé que si le gouvernement
n'avait pas le courage
d'entreprise d'entreprendre ses actions
s'il laissait des secteurs entiers
pourrir lentement il n aurait aucune
chance aucune chance que les jeunes
Françaises et les jeunes Français est un
emploi rémunérateur à la fin de ce de ce
siècle et si au contraire cet effort est
bien conduit s'il est accompagné comme
je le souhaite et je vais revenir d'une
symétrie sociale appropriée alors je
suis convaincu qu'une politique de cette
nature est celle qui peut assurer la
croissance économique de la France et un
emploi à chaque Français d'une manière
générale le président juscardestin a
souhaité que tout soit fait pour faire
reculer l'injustice en France laurencein
alors en effet il prévoit des mesures en
faveur des personnes défavorisées et ces
personnes défavorisées ce sont
essentiellement les personnes âgées et
les familles pour les personnes âgées le
Président annonce une revalorisation du
minimum vieillesse qui passe de 11000 à
12000 francs au 1er juillet et non 1er
octobre comme c'était prévu il annonce
aussi que le versement des pensions de
retraite sera amélioré parce que il a
rit souvent que les retraités juste
après leur retraite attendent plusieurs
mois avant de recevoir les premiers
versements donc ce versement sera
accéléré il y aura aussi une
amélioration des reversions de pension
alors ça c'est les personnes âgées
maintenant les familles alors d'abord
une revalorisation des du pouvoir
d'achat des prestations familiales qui
sera allié au président plus forte que
celle des années précédentes et puis le
président de la République a rappelé
aussi l'allongement du congé maternité
de 2 semaines ce qu'avait déjà annoncé
Simone veille mais il a annoncé une
mesure nouvelle c'est l'assurance vie
obligatoire pour les mères de famille
pour les mères de famille afin qu'en cas
de décès il y ait une garantie de
sécurité de ressources alors ça c'est le
domaine une partie du domaine social
mais il y a aussi un domaine dans lequel
le président a déclaré ne pas vouloir
intervenir mais souhaiter que il y ait
une plus grande vitalité une plus grande
action c'est celui de la politique
contractuelle c'est-à-dire des
négociations du dialogue entre les le
patronat public ou privé et les
syndicats alors justement il a rappelé
que quatre grandes négociations
contractuelles étaient engagées entre
syndicat patronat sans compter six
négociations particulières par branche
et puis d'autres dans le secteur public
et il a souhaité que cette politique
aboutisse très
rapidement je considère que le début de
ces négociations à l'heure actuelle est
un rythme qui me paraît plutôt lent et
je souhaite qu'il soit qu'elle soit
conduite de telle manière qu'il puisse y
avoir de premiers résultats à l'automne
et je considérerai Mme comme
significatif qu'il puisse y avoir un ou
deux résultats de la politique
contractuelle avant
l'été je confirme solennellement à cet
égard l'engagement de maintien du
pouvoir d'achat voilà venons-en
maintenant à la 3è et dernière partie de
cet exposé présidentiel la politique
étrangère avec un fort noyau africain
nous le verrons tout à l'heure mais
d'abord ce que le président a dit de la
détente avec cette phrase très nette il
n'y a pas d'alternative à la détente
George B oui ça c'est une profession de
foi pour commencer cela dit Monsieur
liscardestin reconnaît que la détente ne
se porte pas aussi bien qu'elle l'a plus
se porortter jadis et il explique
pourquoi il dit que la détente ça doit
comporter un code de bonne conduite en
quelque sorte et que la détente doit
être quelque chose de mondial et ne pas
se localiser uniquement en Europe et que
par exemple quand on franchit des
frontières en Afrique et bien c'est
contre la détente et justement monsieur
Giscard destin a écrit à Monsieur brenf
la semaine dernière pour lui expliquer
que les actions françaises en Afrique ne
sont pas contre la détente mais pour la
détente puisqu'elles tendent justement à
stabiliser l'ordre des choses existant
en Afrique chef de l'État a également
évoquer mais plus rapidement les
problèmes du désarmement les travaux en
cours font apparaître un certain
consensus et je souhaite qu'il puisse se
matérialiser lors de la session spéciale
de l'ONU il a aussi parlé de son
prochain voyage en Espagne l'acte de
confiance qui était le mien dans la
démocratisation de ce pays sous la
conduite de son roi a été largement
confirmé par les faites et puis un
passage aussi sur la situation situation
au Liban il s'agit maintenant de
réaliser la seconde mission les
Israéliens ayant évacué le sud Liban qui
est de permettre au gouvernement
libanais de rétablir toute sa
souveraineté sur le sud Liban enfin et
surtout vous disais-je la justification
de la politique africaine de la FR les
actions que la France a été conduit à
entreprendre en Afrique ont abouti à
trois
résultats d'abord les actions de la
France ont au total et vous allez le
voir servi a stabilisé l'Afrique
elles ont prouvé ensuite dans le monde
que la France avait la capacité d'agir
et qu'elle avait la volonté de tenir ses
engagements
elles ont enfin donné confiance aux
coopérants français publics et privés en
ce qui concerne la protection de leur
sécurité je rappelle parce que c'est
important de le dire que ces actions ont
toujours été défensiv
qu'elles ont toujours été limitées dans
le temps et qu'elles ont toujours été
orientées vers la recherche de solutions
politiques
elles n'ont été entreprises qu'à la
demande instante des gouvernements
intéressés les actions quelles
sont-elles je vais les passer rapidement
en revue en réponse à vos question il y
a d'abord l'action qui s'est déroulée au
Shabbat cette action s'est achevée cet
après-midi même puisque le dernier
élément français qui se trouvait à
colvisie a quitté colvisie cet
après-midi et s'embarquera demain de
l'ubumbachi en direction de la France il
n'y aura donc plus aucun militaire
français sur le territoire du
zaï cette action a été entreprise pour
sauver des vies humaines et je m'étonne
de la question la présence entation que
je préfère ne pas qualifier qui a été
parfois donné de cette action comme si
c'était à l'origine de l'armée
zaïroisees qui avait provoqué ces
événements il y a une armée zaïroise
depuis maintenant 16 ans au Zaïr il y a
de très nombreuses européens partout
dans le Zaïr et ce n'est pas l'armée
zaïroise qui les a où que ce soit
attaqué ou mise en danger il faudrait
donc pas que à des fins évidemment
évidemment partisan on dénature à ce
point l'évidence des choses lorsque les
événements du zaï du Chabat ont commencé
à se dérouler nous avons vérifié un
certain nombre de données de la
situation il s'agissait de savoir s'il
s'agissait d'éléments venus de
l'extérieur et il s'agissait de savoir
s'il mettait en danger la sécurité des
Européens et en particulier de nos
compatriotes et c'est lorsque nous avons
eu la certitude sur ces deux points que
nous avons décidé d'entreprendre une
action et après cette information sur le
retrait des parfrançais de colwayisi et
d'une façon générale du Chabat il y a eu
un moment d'ironie dans les propos du
chef de l'État oui monsieur jcardesttin
un petit peu ironisé sur ceux qui
auraient voulu que l'expédition
française soit précédée d'un débat
parlementaire et que pendant 48 he on
discute iront iront pas de telle sorte
que les les rebelles du chabaess que les
parafançais justement allaient tomb du
ciel c'estàdire qu'il n'aurait plus
aucun élément de décision de surprise
militaire si vous voulez voilà puis
alors bien entendu à part le Chabin
aussi le Tchad la Mauritanie la
Mauritanie la Mauritanie monsieur lcard
destin a souligné qui n'y avait pas
proprement parlé de trou français il n'y
a que des coopérants et les Français
sont intervenus en 78 cette année ils
sont intervenus une fois une fois sur
les lieux mêmes où il y a eu SEP
français enlevé et deux morts le 1er mai
lors de l'anniversaire de oui et puis
alors il y a le Tchad le Tchad ou le la
France alors les les Français
interviennent a dit Monsieur
jiscarlestin d'une part pour protéger
des ressortissants français bien sûr et
d'autre part à la demande du
gouvernement tchadien pour éviter que ne
soit violé un cesser le feu qui avait
été souscrit par toutes les parties en
présence alors là monsieurcardesttin a
exprimé un espoir que tout cela a
débouché là comme ailleurs en Afrique
d'ailleurs après certaines interventions
françaises sur une solution politique
c'est-à-dire qu'il y aura un accord
entre les partis en présence avec l'aval
des pays riverins a dit le président de
la République autrement dit je pense la
Libye bien sûr voilà vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il y a eu un moment d'une
certaine ironie dans cet exposé sur
l'Afrique il y a eu aussi un moment où
le président de la République a
manifesté tout de même une certaine
indignation effectivement assez
vigoureusement il a dénoncé une campagne
de critique contre les chefs d'État
africains je soutiens la France je vous
laisse l'écouter à ce prop je voudrais
m'élever contre une
campagne que je trouve véritablement
indigne et imprégé là aussi c'est très
frappant d'un relant d'esprit
colonialiste qui est la campagne sur les
dirigeants africains vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que la France soutenait des
régimes corrompus à quel titre et à quel
droit avec quel droit portez-vous un tel
jugement
contester le régime de la République
islamique de maitadie par exemple est un
régime qui est régime d'une parfaite
dignité qui d'ailleurs jusqu'à ces
événements faisait l'objet de la
considération de l'ensemble de ses
partenaires arabes et islamique et je
n'ai rencontré personne personne
n'est-ce pas qui mettent en doute les
qualités hautement respectables du chef
de l'État mauritanien et à quel titre
établirions-nous en Afrique une
classification et d'ailleurs qui la
ferait qui la ferait concernant la
nature des régimes le degré de la
liberté politique les droits de
l'opposition à s'exprimer le nombre
d'exécutions som qui ont eu lieu qui
ferait cette classification la France
connaît des états elle agit vis-à-vis
d'état de gouvernement légitime de C de
ces état comme elle le fait dans le
reste du monde mais nous n'allons pas
garder des souvenirs du passé le droit
d'établir je ne sais quelle
classification de code de valeur en ce
qui concerne les dirigeants de l'Afrique
alors nous en arrivions alors à la
conclusion le chef de l'État au début de
sa conférence de presse avait rappelé
que ses deux premiers objectifs était de
faire de la France une démocratie
paisible et réfléchie et d'en faire une
puiss qui en dehors des deux super
grands soit à la tête des pays qui
conduisent l'évolution de notre temps il
a donc annoncé quelques minutes avant sa
fin son troisème
objectif trè objectif de mon action
c'est que la France entre en bon
état du point de vue
culturel du point de vue politique et du
point de vue social dans le 3è
millénaire ça vous paraîtra peut-être
une ambition très lointaine ou très
abstraite elle ne l'est pas dès à
présent un certain nombre de dossiers
que nous avons à
étudier dossier scientifique dossier
énergétique dossier de défense dossier
d'éducation Dossier de santé sont des
dossiers dont le prolongement don les
prolongements s'étalent sur les 20
prochaines années et donc définiront la
situation la position de la France
lorsqu'elle entrera dans le 3e
millénaire et puisque l'histoire
s'accroche à des
dates je crois qu'il est très important
que notre pays tel qu'il est avec sa
capacité son caractère ses ressources
ses moyens ses ambitions entrent comme
je vous l'ai dit en bon état dans le 3e
millénaire et que à cette occasion il
constitue l'exemple de ce que pourrait
être une société libre
Pacifique juste et qui en même temps
sache s'adapter au progrès et le
conduire en ce qui le consène et c'est
la raison pour laquelle raison profonde
au-delà de d'éléments de circonstance je
souhaite que la France soit désormais
présente dans tous les lieux et dans
tous les
débats voilà j'ajoute que le chef de
l'État renourera avec la tradition
puisque il y aura une autre conférence
de presse dès l'automne au cours de
laquelle il devrait aborder le problème
des inégalités sociales un problème
qu'il voulait aborder aujourd'hui mais
qu'en raison du temps il a été obligé
d'occulter
alors voyons maintenant un petit peu
avec vous alin duamel quelle peut-être
l'impression dominante j'ai l'impression
que c'est l'impression d'une grosse
fermeté une grande fermeté oui moi c'est
ce que en tout cas ce qui m'a frappé à
l'écouter il me semble que dans
l'ensemble il y avait de la part du
président une fermeté je dirais confirmé
même accentué dans certains domaines
alors il me semble que c'est une fermeté
qu'on pouvait voir au fond de deux
façons qui étaient différentes d'une
part parce que dans certains secteurs je
pense essentiellement à ce qui est
politique et à ce qui est social il y
avait si j'ose dire un petit peu une une
seconde vague de giscardisme et puis
d'autre part en ce qui concernait
l'économie et la politique étrangère il
y avait un petit peu un temps nouveau
alors je m'explique en ce qui concerne
en ce qui concerne la politique ce qui
est très clair dans dans tout ce qu'il a
dit c'est qu'au fond il poursuit une
entreprise de modernisation de la vie
politique en France un petit peu sur un
modèle anglo-saxon alors vous savez
qu'il avait déjà fait des choses après
avoir ét du président par exemple le
vote à 18 an ou par exemple la réforme
du Conseil
constitutionnel cette fois-ci il y a pas
mal de choses nouvelles qui vont depuis
l'étude du financement publque des
partis politiques qui est très important
et qui se fait en Grande-Bretagne en
Italie en Allemagne fédérale aux
États-Unis mais pas en France maintenant
bon jusqu'à la poursuite du dialogue
avec l'opposition puisqu'il a annoncé
que avant les prochains sommets il
aurait à nouveau des contacts avec des
leaders de l'opposition en fait il y a
beaucoup d'autres choses qui vont depuis
le droit de réponse dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure jusqu'au problème du
cumule des mandats ça c'est la
modernisation politique seconde vague
comme il en avait fait une après avoir
été alors dans le domaine social alors
voilà dans le domaine social il a dit
c'est ça oui c'est c'est la tentative de
réduction des injustices alors ça il le
fait si j'ose dire de deux façons d'une
part sur un plan social ponctuel ce
qu'il a annoncé à propos de personnes
âgées des familles et cetera et d'autre
part ce qui alors est probablement à
terme et je crois que la durée c'est une
chose importante là en l'occurrence
d'autre part son son idée de la société
française et au fond c'est un peu sa
formule la France au français ce qui
signifie au fond tout ce qui tourne
autour des thèmes de participation de
logement individuel c'est un peu l'idée
qui était dans son livre démocratie
française de de patrimoine minimum si
vous voulez l'accès plus facile au
patrimoine de de chaque Français ça je
crois que c'est la seconde idée et et là
aussi il y a l'esquisse d'une seconde
vague moins net que pour la première
mais l'esquisse d'une seconde vague et
c'est peut-être dans le domaine de la
politique étrangère que l'on voit la
plus grande fermeté alors voilà alors là
dans le domaine de la politique
étrangère c'est je dirais une forme de
de cohérence et puis un ton qui était
particulièrement ferm alors je trouve
que c'était surtout sensible de deux
façons d'une part à propos de la détente
en règle générale quand il expliquait
pourquoi la détente était global bon ce
qui était une idée qui vous savez en ce
moment était une idée qui était
contestée naturellement bon d'autre part
à propos de ce qu'il a dit sur l'Afrique
alors d'abord on sent bien que c'est un
sujet qui suit de très très près la
façon dont il a bien précisé qu'il
fallait dire les actions françaises en
Afrique et pas l'Action française en
Afrique j'ajoute que le président qui
avait peu de note en avait précisément
ou oui c'était très clair et puis on
voyait très bien il y avait le zaï qui
n'était pas le Chad qui n'était pas la
Mauritanie et cetera enfin il expliquait
les les problème sur un ton qui était
très décidé avec tout de même l'idée qui
est importante et qui était liée à
l'idée précédente que l'Action française
en Afrique non seulement n'est pas du
tout contradictoire avec la détente à
son avis mais que pour lui au contraire
c'est un élément de stabilisation donc
de de de respect de ce code de bonne
conduite dont il parlait est-ce qu'on a
une petite idée de ce que peuvent être
les réactions de l'opposition à ses
quelques démarches dans sa dans sa
direction non je pense que comme
toujours si vous voulez sur ce qui est
dans l'ensemble pour l'opposition ça ça
ne peut pas changer grand-chose à son
comportement actuel il a d'ailleurs eu
un petit coup de patte à François
mitteran à propos de l'Afrique euh je
pense que l'opposition sera intéressée
sans doute par justement l'aspect de
modernisation de vie politique pour le
reste qui touche à l'économie à la
politique étrangère ou à la politique
socienne ça ne changera pas Grand- chose
pour l'opposition et elle sera donc
critique vis-à-vis de des partenaires de
la majorité il y a eu l'idée que le
pluralisme organisé avait fonctionné
convenablement et et on pouvait relever
au passage que pour lui le pluralisme
organisé fonctionne convenablement quand
il fonctionne au Parlement et autrement
dit si dans la vie des partis il y a des
dissentiments par exemple entre le RPR
l'UDF à un moment donné bon ça comme
président ça ne le concerne pas
directement bien de toute façon nous
aurons une preuve concrète de ce que
pensent à la fois les partenaires
sociaux et syndicaux et politiques
puisque je vous le rappelle François
mitteran sera notre invité mardi au
courant de ce journal de 20h et que
François Serac est notre invité lors de
notre émission samedi et nuit alors
venons-en maintenant aux réactions de la
journée dans les heures qui ont suivi la
conférence pour Gaston Plissonnier au
nom du parti communiste Monsieur
giscardtin S fait le champ du
réocolonialisme en défendant
l'impossible dossier de la politique
interventionniste en Afrique le Parti
socialiste par la VO de claudier prend
acte des intentions du président
concernant le dialogue il regrette que
le droit de réponse soit toujours
envisagé de façon restrictive Michel CRP
estime que le mouvement des Radicaux de
Gauche a été le premier à saisir
l'opinion au sujet du financement des
partis politiques il rappelle que le MRG
déposera une proposition de loi à ce
sujet la semaine prochaine Victor le
duuc pour le PSU a déclaré que le
président a évité toute réponse
concernant le chômage et l'inflation il
se contente a-t-il dit des vieilles
recettes habituelles Jean lecuet annonce
que l'UDF fera bientôt des propositions
pour que l'injustice sociale recule
l'UDF veut également contribuer à
faciliter l'ouverture à l'intérieur de
l'UDF Jacques Blanc pour le Pr donne
raison aux Français d'avoir choisi
d'être gouverné pour une société
solidaire pour une France respectée le
CDS affirme Bernard stasie contribuera à
chercher des solutions pour la
limitation du cumul des mandats et le
financement des partis politiques pas
encore réaction du côté des Radicaux
valoisiens de JJSS pas encore aussi non
plus de réaction du RPR qui attendra
sans doute demain matin avant de dire ce
qu'il pense de la Réunion dans les
colonnes de la lettre de la nation son
quotidien Bertrand le CNIP apportera
tout son appui à la nécessité de la
politique libérale tel que Valée
gcardestin vient de la clarifier Michel
Jobert souhaite que la description
pardon paisible de l'avenir que vient de
faire le président soit plus juste que
son analyse
précédente
pour la CGT les développements laborieux
du président sur la politique économique
et sociale cachent bien mal un avenir
lourd de menace pour les travailleur
pour la CFDT Valérie giscardestin s'est
contenté de prendre acte du chômage et
de l'inflation et il laisse les mains
libres au
patronat André Bergeron Force Ouvrière
pense que le rythme des négociations
actuelles est trop lent et il note
l'engagement du chef de l'État de
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat pour la CGC
giscar est trop optimiste sur l'emploi
mais les distributions d'action sont
intéressantes Haus satisfaction la
garantie du pouvoir d'achat
voilà le reste de l'actualité maintenant
avec tout d'abord dans le domaine social
nous y étions presque Renault climat de
détente aujourd'hui à la Régie qui vient
par ailleurs de conclure avec la
Roumanie un accord de coopération qui
porterait sur plus de 4 milliards de
francs le remembrement mise en cause
pour la première fois par le tribunal de
Rennes après les inondations de Morley
il y a 4 ans le tribunal a reconnu le
remembrement comme un facteur aggravant
des crru et puis les autres points
chauds en quelques télégramme vous allez
le voir des nuages noirs sur Brest où
les grevistes occupent toujours
l'arsenal les chiffres du chômage pour
mai et puis la réunion des ministre de
l'OCDE pour examiner la situation
économique mondiale tout cela en image
après la grève décidée hier à une forte
majorité par les ouvriers de l'arsenal
de Brest le travail s'est arrêté
aujourd'hui à Saint-Étienne
ClermontFerrand Lorient et cherbour
cette extension du conflit concerne
110000 ouvriers et techniciens du
personnel civil de la Défense nationale
à l'origine le refus du ministre de la
défense de redonner à ce personnel le
statut de la M
[Applaudissements]
en mai dernier le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi sélev observ 17000 soit 9000
chômeurs de moins qu'en avril mais 61000
de plus qu'en mai de l'année dernière ce
ralentissement du chômage correspond en
effet saisonnier habituel et ne se
prolongera pas durant les mois suivants
un gonflement du nombre des demandeurs
d'emploi est en effet attendu à la fin
de l'année scolaire en
cours relancer l'économie des pays
occidentaux est-ce possible et qui doit
commencer ce sont les deux questions qui
vont dominer la réunion des ministres de
l'économie des 24 pays de l'OCDE cette
réunion qui s'est ouverte aujourd'hui à
Paris devra préparer l'entretien au
sommet des 16 et 17 juillet entre les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement des 7
principaux pays
occidentaux protestation du bureau
politique du parti communiste français
contre le refus des socialistes de
constituer des listes d'union pour les
élections municipales partielles qui se
dérouleront dimanche prochain dans en
trois communes ex en Provence flair et
brillance le 100000e passager sur le
Concord Air France est un industriel
allemand un habitué de la ligne
Munich Rio il en était à son 15e voyage
à bord du supersonic français et si Air
France avec le Concorde à le monopole de
la vitesse l'autre compagnie nationale
je veux parler d'Air Inter avait jusqu'à
l'an dernier celui de la ponctualité il
est vrai que l'on a pu enregistrer sur
différentes lignes quelques retards don
l'un et vous le savez est à l'origine
d'un procès et ce n'est pas faute
pourtant pour r inter d'avoir acquis des
techniques de pointe ce qui se fait de
mieux pratiquement à la
matière la tenue d'axe est effectuée et
la tenue de vitesse est assurée
entièrement
automatiquement nous arrivons dans
quelques instants à 30
m 15
m et voici notre hauteur de décision et
l'avion va à l'instant
impacter il impacte vous voyez que même
la tenue de guidage est faite
automatiquement et maintenant il va bien
falloir freiner c'est la seule
action l'inversion de
poussée est
obten et le freinage va être appliqué
que je suis en train de
faire là je viens de débrayer l'ensemble
autopilot l'ATT l'atterrissage tout
temps est le principal atout de la
régularité des rinter ce système qui
permet une approche entièrement
automatique et sans visibilité équipe la
plupart des appareils de la compagnie à
l'exception des fers cet investissement
sur Caravel d'abord sur Mercure et
Airbus ensuite avait placé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année 77 la compagnie
intérieure au premier rang mondial de la
ponctualité au cours du premier
trimestre de cette année Herin a perdu
son cordon bleu ravi par
luftanza c'est comme dans le sport
n'est-ce pas la difficulté c'est de
garder la médaille ce n'est pas de
peut-être de l'obtenir ça paraître un
paradoxe quelqu'un a fait mieux que nous
et puis comme je vous l'ai dit les
causes que nous avons subis le fait
peut-être que nous avions déjà eu cette
médaille internationale euh je ne dirais
pas qu'il y a eu un relâchement mais il
n'y a plus la conscience qu'il fallait
être aussi tendu sur chaque minute et
sur chaque seconde Air Inter assure
chaque jour 250 vols intérieurs avec une
flotte aérienne de 3 Airbus 10 mercure 5
Caravel 12 16 Caravel 3 et 9 fcker 27
557 commandants de bord pilotes et
mécanicien 584 auess et Steewart arme
ses appareils pour transporter
quotidiennement 20000 passagers un balai
parfaitement réglé mais une jonglerie
permanente pour respecter l'horaire les
rotations sont serrées et la durée des
escales calculées au plus juste les
causes de retard sont multiples elles
peuvent être d'ordre technique elles
peuvent également comme c'est souvent le
cas dépendre du contrôle aérien dans ce
mécano géant d'Orly West ou deorwissi
air interre comme Air France n'a aucune
priorité lorsqu'un avion prend du retard
au décollage ou à l'atterrissage ce
retard se répercute souvent sur toutes
les rotations que doit effectuer
l'appareil dans la journée une fausse
note il faut tout réharmoniser c'est le
travail du personnel au sol les
contraintes sont nombreuses mais on
pense avant tout à la
sécurité il n'est pas question pour nous
en tant que syndicat de mettre en cause
et de faire bon marché de la sécurité
nous préférons dans ce caslà que
éventuellement la la ponctualité soit un
peu affecté mais je crois que c'est le
souci également des passagers et je
pense pas qu' puisse nous nous
désapprouver a inter transportera cette
année près de 6 millions de passagers
son objectif est d'atteindre les 7
millions et demi en 1982 queles que soi
les causes de retard lié à la météo la
circulation aérienne les problèmes
d'effectifs ou de flottees la compagnie
devra accentuer son effort pour
reconquérir le cordon bleu de la
ponctualité si elle veut continuer à
être compétitive notamment contre le
train à grande vitesse la clientèle de
la compagnie est composée à 80 %
d'hommes d'affaires ils veulent partir
et arriver à
l'heure à l'étranger maintenant il n'y
aura pas de prochaines rencontre Carter
Castro les Américains n'ont pas beaucoup
apprécié le manque de diplomatie du
premier cubain qui a accusé les
conseillers du président Carter de le
manipuler et de le tromper la tension
est vive au Nord-Liban où Tony frangier
assassiné hier avec sa famille a été
enterré dans son village natal les
casques verts syriens ont pris position
entre les combattants chrétiens de
frangier et les militants fallangistes
en football maintenant après quelques
jours d'interruption c'est reparti pour
le mondial dans le groupe a l'Italie et
l'Allemagne s'affrontait il y a quelques
heures vous l'avez vu en direct sur
cette antenne en même temps que
l'Autriche et la Hollande l'Autriche qui
a été écrasée 5 à1 par la Hollande ce
qui est une surprise considérable tandis
que le groupe B à dominante
sud-américaine rassemble l'Argentine le
Brésil le Pérou et la Pologne nous
allons voir les principales actions de
la rencontre Allemagne-Italie avec André
bodigal
nous sommes ici en première mi-temps les
Allemands jouent en blanc à gauche les
Italiens sont en bleu tandis que les
allemandst dominé le début de la
rencontre à partir de la 25e minutes les
Italiens prennent nettement l'avantage
et sur cette action bet le numéro 18
récupère un bon service de Paolo Rossi
pour se retrouver devant 7 meilleur et
bet tire un tir que dét en catastrophe
le numéro 5 allemand
CZ nous revoyons l'action ralenti le
score à la mi-temps 0
partout nous jouons maintenant en
seconde mi-temps sur ce corner cavrini
récupère la balle et tire sur les
poteaux bet encore lui reprend de volet
Mayer est battu et c'est cal une
nouvelle fois qui sauve les buts
allemands la B action au ralenti
finalement et malgré une nette
domination des Italiens la rencontre se
terminera sur un score nul 0
[Applaudissements]
partout il y avait un tirage du Loto
aujourd'hui et voici la combinaison
gagnante avec les 6 numéros le 1 le 6 le
10 le 12 le 14 et le 49 avec vous le
voyez comme numéro complémentaire le 35
dernière page de ce journal avec la
météo et tout d'abord le temps qu'il a
fait aujourd'hui ensoleillé sur la
moitié nord avec une net remontée des
températures ce qui est une bonne chose
et nuageux voire orageux sur la moitié
sud les provisions pour demain
maintenant avec une autre carte moitié
nord du soleil et qu quelques nuages
température en hausse moitié sud un
temps nuageux accompagné de pluies
orageuses notamment sur le Massif
Central les Alpes et le Jura température
stationnaire dans cette moitié sud vous
avez deux rendez-vous avec la rédaction
d'Antenne 2 ce soir le premier à 22h25
c'est le magasine question de temps qui
aura ce soir pour thème à chacun sa
santé avec une enquête de btiurau le
second c'est bien entendu la dernière
édition de ce journal aux alentours de
23h30 et c'est Patrick lecock qui vous
la présentera voilà quant à moi je
termine ce journal asse chargé et
beaucoup plus long qu'à l'habitude en
vous souhaitant une excellente soirée et
je vous retrouverai demain avec un très
très grand plaisir merci de votre
attention et bonsoir à
[Musique]
tous